[Music]
i have a story of this guy
who did this very specific type of lipo
and he walked out with a six-pack and a
whole
built ass buff-ass body oh [ __ ] yeah so
this is what he looked like before looks
like me right now
this is you right now i do have the same
underwear no
i see the vibe though yeah yeah yeah and
then this was the
after where is it after oh my god what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] are those all the
entry points what's gross about it
that's dumb
so yeah you turn into a superhero oh i
thought that was fake muscles
you have to do [ __ ] like bart look at
what bart has to do to himself
for this but i still don't look like him
but he's going to get it all back
because he's really
jacked he doesn't know how to maintain
it well if he keeps doing this he'll be
fine can we go back to the old picture
you're not wrong
was it lipo yeah so it's a certain type
of lipo
i'll check right now with the exact name
starts with the v
but that type of like lipo it goes in
ultrasonically and so it targets
fat cells under the tissue so it doesn't
actually
damage a lot of the other tissue that's
not fat cells like other liposuction
and so with this one it's actually so
easy
and like non not super invasive that
they just they
ana anastasia anesthetize you what
they numb you up locally namaste
can you go back to the other picture
he's all jacked yeah let's keep it there
they do his face too
so that's the thing that kind of made me
laugh because i was like they did
all this but they missed the face or is
he going to do another
oh he's like a buff hamster because it
looks kind of round a little bit and
still around the neck it's weird yeah
but down here he looks like
like he's ripped yeah he looks good
there's like once he's healed
wow i think your body slowly tries to
even it out after
doesn't it so it sucks all the fat from
the cheeks and it goes to one fat arm
right it has to slowly try to
like make it even i don't know that guy
looks [ __ ]
jack thought how did this happen well
like i said
the ultra ultrasonic lipo dude the
future is so hot we're all gonna be so
hot what's ultrasonic lipo
where it goes underneath in the fat
tissue and it it actually targets the
fat tissue and then like it
ultrasonic it like vibrates it and then
it like
disintegrates the fat cells and so
you're able to
actually like pinpoint exactly where it
is that you want to
suction and or like break apart the fat
cells and so that's how they're able to
sculpt this dude
so if he has a if he wants like he has a
fat ass he wants to keep his fat ass and
like don't touch it
but yeah so then it's saying that it
could help with those stubborn areas
such as
love handles or whatever stubborn areas
they [ __ ] took his whole body out
dude i know
this one's good for people that just
want to get like stubborn fat
pockets it's because people are are
always trying to target
areas of fat they're like oh how do i
just get this or whatever
so does it work like that it's a genius
business idea cause you can
actually target now you can just walk in
and go like
you want to target that tummy let's do
it just remember
you how do you know how to maintain
keep that back every six months it's
good for the business owners
yeah that's what he said too that like
he's gonna
do his best to keep up with with the
actual like healthy lifestyle to
maintain that look but he says like he
would not hesitate to go again
yeah he's not gonna do it he's not
giving up taco bell [ __ ] yeah he's
not gonna do it yeah he's
he's definitely working strong yeah they
didn't just carve those muscles in
yeah yeah he already had the muscles
they're just covered yeah yeah but now
they removed the covering now he's just
like now i can eat burgers for every
meal and still work out
and look jack kind of you could see some
something happening
he has pegs his pecs that's a good idea
he's already strong
looking yeah you can see the abs
underneath yeah there's like abs under
there
so he said that the reason why he wanted
to do this procedure is because he
wanted to keep up with his hot wife
and his two kids he's too hot
i was waiting for that he has a 12 year
old and a 20 year old
and they're both like really into
fitness and like going to the gym and
stuff and so he just felt like he looked
like
he didn't belong in the family so this
is his wife
[ __ ] is amazing so he's like my wife has
gotten a lot of cosmetic procedures i'm
like why not treat
he looks bigger over here this is after
i think
yeah so it's pretty pretty impressive
wow
seeing these before and after is just
like what do you know how much the
procedure costs
i don't it's a good question are you
considering it
oh i i don't like [ __ ] with my body
too much it's 15 000 british pounds
i don't know 15 000. that's like five
zero or one five
oh one five like 17 years 20
20 000. nice that's like 20 grand as
much
as many areas as you want well for his
we had a lot of work done though yeah it
looked like all upper body
except for the cheeks exactly yeah
that's what it looked like
shoulder to torso i don't know i was i
was like damn this is tight
if you have the money and you want to
look good how fast do you think that can
be gained back though if you don't
change your eating how fast [ __ ]
a month you ever watch survivor at the
end of the show they're like all [ __ ]
skinny as [ __ ] and then when
they do the reunion thing like the final
episode after where it's like everyone's
been home for
like a month and everyone's like back to
normal it's wild
what they like used to look like yeah
yeah yeah yeah i wonder if they get
stretch marks and stuff like that like
drastic it can
it really can yeah it's crazy i'm
surprised science hasn't come to a point
where they can just give you muscles yet
science you know well they could grow
they can take away fat but there's
nothing where it's just like
boom steroids yeah steroids
i mean you still have to work for it
though you still have to work where you
do have to work for it yeah i think what
he's saying it's just like you go to
sleep you wake up
boom buff damn okay now now you can
but then you need the muscles though can
they grow muscle fibers
in like a petri dish or if they put you
in a coma and like
put on the electric stimulus thing but
like constantly
has your body while you're asleep for
like a week oh yeah that's like that
and then also inject you with steroids
at the same time so then when you wake
up you're super big damn
you're like the laziest fit person on
earth yeah like those electro stim
machines
right yeah yeah you're constantly just
like flexing and sleeping
doing that for 24 hours a day for like
two weeks straight
with a ton of steroids yeah i did this
one thing
that was really interesting but it was
like a lymphatic drain
like lymphatic drainage procedure kind
of thing
and uh it was through the class past
stuff so it was like
wellness like it's categorized as
wellness but they
they wrapped all these like weird like
it was kind of like a cast
like a body cast and they massage the
crap out of you and it's
yeah it's like certain like pulses that
they give in certain parts of my body at
certain times
so it's like a wave of pulses all
throughout my body
and it's pretty much targeting the
lymphatic nodes
and so they end up draining all that and
for for the last
for the next like two or three days
after that i just started getting muscle
twitches and random oh you got it done
yeah
did you feel healthier i don't know i
don't a wellness thing isn't they just
did it so that you could be
like hey look you're healthier like that
yeah it's supposed to be
good for you to drain out your your
lymph nodes
what are lymph nodes lymphatic drainage
i like to drain out the two lymph nodes
that i have in a sac you drain them
daily
oh yeah yeah well lymph nodes are part
of your immune system
yeah i always thought it was right here
it's everywhere there's like here here
there's here there's here there's here
there's here
there's a
it's like a filter oh yeah yeah so then
it swells up when you get like a virus
or something that's why the doctor
is always oh you're sick man yeah you
could you could they will swallow before
you get sick so it's almost like a
precursor you're like oh here we go
they're located here but they're
connected to everything they're
everywhere located everywhere yeah yeah
they are everywhere it's a system like a
whole
like a nervous this one the one that's
easiest because the doctor can do this
and then check your lymph nodes oh but
then you'll be like
why are you doing that it's the most
accessible no i think that one also is
like for
like the cold or whatever it is like
your symptoms are up here so that's why
these are swollen but like if you have
an infection on your leg
or something it would be a little closer
yeah yeah i like it when he's like
they're like
lymph nodes in my balls like i like that
one like here let me check here
let me see my lymph nodes there's one
right here too yeah yeah there's a
couple here
yeah these get swollen yeah two yeah
they do
so if i feel sick i should just be like
just feel the ones here if you're sick
no no no like if you if your throat's
[ __ ] up or whatever
like yeah it's up here or drain the one
between your legs yeah there's also like
manual
drainage like like things that you can
do to like massage
and manually drain out your lymph nodes
wow i just googled it
because that's what this guy did dude
have you seen cryotherapy [ __ ] that
shit's interesting
i was watching some undertaker
documentary don't ask me how i got there
i got undertaker like the the wrestler
oh i thought you were talking about like
okay
he was sick to the sickest one and he
did cryotherapy
like just so he could do wrestlemania
every year and he would only wrestle one
time a year like the past couple years
of his career
cryotherapy was a thing back then
no no this is like this is like three
years two years ago oh that's that thing
where you get into like some super cold
like refrigeration
at you yeah he retired now but but this
was about his like last year
i mean isn't it the same a similar
concept that's just jumping in like a
bathtub
yeah it's like cold like fancier so
what's the purpose of that what does
that do
muscle recovery yeah yeah i don't know
the actual mechanism but it's supposed
to help you recover
it reduces inflammation yeah especially
athletes that need to perform constantly
if you're constantly inflamed then
you're prone to getting injured so
it'll reduce it so that your body's
fresh again i mean these cats [ __ ]
their bodies up for
like three thirty years yeah and so yeah
he he needs it
he would do all that just to wrestle for
one night a year
for wrestlemania only one year for like
the last like couple years of his career
damn wow that's crazy i know
super great because we know uh uh what
is he a 70 year old wrestler or whatever
yeah and the way that he [ __ ] runs
and
uses his body it's crazy dude cause you
guys were just saying throwing yourself
into
just the ropes within the ring was
already hurts
though the way he smacks you the way he
falls on the ground
like i thought pick me up something too
he did have cowboy boots and then the
way he falls he [ __ ] full commit
falls
um and he's a stunt dude and the way
that he's like yeah
like he wasn't even he was in the wwf
but then he wasn't even
like hulk hogan are those guys and then
it's like imagine
the level they were easy yeah he says
back then too they would just
uh use blades and cut themselves with
real blood and [ __ ] i've seen a lot of
that
rick flair did that he's like famous for
it like [ __ ] [ __ ] his
forehead up and having blood coming out
true carnies man
[Music]
you